hi my name is Joe Garnier I'm a chess
teacher in the st. Louis area who is
doing a little guest lecture here at the
Chess Club and we're gonna look at one
of my favorite games of all time and
this is a game played between mark
Tamina and Miguel Knight are from the
tournament
Zurich in 1953 and what I love about
this games it's a great demonstration of
the initiative in chess and how when
you're trying to attack you need to
force your will upon your opponent
you're gonna notice like they play a
fairly traditional Orthodox line and
then there comes a point where white
simply just runs out of things to do and
then blacks initiative becomes
overwhelming so we're gonna go through
the first part of this game fairly
quickly since the moves are routine and
then go a little slower as we get into
the middle game to talk about the
specifics so it starts off with white
playing d4 Knight of 6 c4 this is all
typical Kings Indian theory so we don't
need to spend too much time on it
castles like obviously there's other
variations and choices but that's not
the focus here you 5 you can't win this
pawn because there's some tactics with
the night taking e4 a little later
I just tried to draw an arrow it didn't
work so forget that needless to say it's
white can't try to win this pawn by
taking here because then there's a
tactic where you put the knight on e4
and the bishop opens up on you five so
use your imagination because I don't
know how to use this anyway so you five
castles knight c6 that's just done to
provoke white into closing the position
and this is a big change because back
here okay we have this potential for the
position to open and now with it closed
everything becomes very static and pace
of the game slows down both sides kind
of have time to plot things out
so black sees the attack and moves back
white moves back so can anyone tell me
what the point of this move Knight e1 is
anybody what's the idea I got to get the
class involved
and unblock the eft-1 right and what
else besides unblocking that pun the
movie 91 has another maybe even more
important reason than just unblocking
the f-pawn exactly the Knight's
rerouting to either C 2 or D 3 is really
constructive because there's white
against the Kings Indian you try to play
on the queenside which if you can see my
cursor is over here black on the other
here I'm gonna try to play on the King
side and this repositioning is possible
because the centre is completely closed
so you put the knight back on e1 it can
transfer to d3 later it can control c5
and begin White's initiative on the
Queen side so let's go on with it black
points 97 this was done for basically
the same reason he wants to unblock his
F pawn he wants to play f5 maybe f4
eventually and conduct the King side
attack and next few moves white just
goes about attacking on the Queen side
and black goes without attacking on the
King side and they ignore each other so
Bishop e3 now v f3 f4 attacking the
bishop bishop f2 g5 okay so it's pretty
obvious with blacks trying to do here
right he's just trying to push the pawns
forward and go attack the white king but
he hasn't made any real threats yet so
black although some aggressive posturing
he hasn't really seized the initiative
just yet and the next few moves you're
gonna see that change so Knight d3 kinda
as we talked about Knight of 6 same
reason you want to bring the knight back
over to the Kings side where you're
going to attack c5 Knight g6 and both
sides are just ignoring each other
rook c1 rook f7 okay rook up 7 is like
sort of this multi-purpose move in the
Kings Indian won it obviously protects
the c7 pawn but it also allows you to do
this maneuver where the rook comes to g7
and then this Bishop comes to f8 and
defends the d6 pawn anyway rook c2 is
kind of done for the same reason it
provides some lateral defense of the a
King side but then also the possibility
to double rooks on the C file later
Bishop f8 like we just talked about pawn
takes pawn and
how would you take back you got the pawn
you got the bishop you got the Queen in
my mind there's only one decent option
raise your hand if you want the pawn
take back all right anybody else for
anything else all right everybody's
right good
so Fon takes pawn and because we want to
maintain everything in the center we
don't want to have to worry about you
know the c5 square getting kicked around
and all that stuff I think it takes
Queen d2 g4 rooks c1 and up unto this
point like both sides have basically
been ignoring each other and so now
comes the point in the lecture where are
the game I should say where black takes
the initiative so what do you think
black did in this position and for those
have you seen the game before at least
wait 30 seconds what should black do
right now at least I hope it's right now
in my recollection of this game is
correct where we're taking a big risk
has been 30 seconds Erik you've seen
this before he hasn't really thought you
were in the camp or something okay
all right what would you do g3 all right
so you're gonna sacrifice in the palm of
g3 right so we got to calculate this
because that is the correct answer and
it seizes it seizes the initiative but
it sacrificed is upon and this is where
night off takes control of the game the
concept of forcing moves is really
important here force moves or checks
captures and direct attacks anything
that keeps the initiative and keeps you
putting forcing your will upon your
opponent so moving along g3 takes takes
takes we're in an important moment here
we just sacrificed a pawn but we have an
initiative but we need to keep it so
what move do we think blacks should play
alright what was your name again
Caleb where'd you go Knight to age five
and they're definitely on the menus
things to consider it brings the knight
closer to the white king it does so with
the gain in time by attacking the bishop
there's other decent moves here but this
is the really direct one it's the one
that makes the threat and it's the one
that forces white to respond you know
the good thing about forcing moves is
they're easier to calculate like if
you're sitting here and you're
considering rook
g7 which is probably a perfectly
reasonable move
well how many decent moves does white
have in this position - 320 you know no
but when it's a forcing move it's easy
to calculate so you play Knight h5 you
know that um White's gonna have to move
this Bishop and it's easy to calculate
so sorry I'm like stumbling through this
because I'm trying to figure out the
computer while I'm talking so it's not
easy anyway Bishop h2 Bishop e7 now
somebody tell me what Bishop e7
threatens this is an important one I
need to stop giving hints with the
cursor but anyway what is the threat and
yes exactly it threatens to play Bishop
g5 because that's a skewer and that's
that's good for black so white defends
it Knight B 1 so through what tactic
does that defend against the Bishop g5
secure yeah
exactly so just to do the side variation
let's say we go from Bishop g5 all right
and um all right hold on I'm not over
right new variation okay Bishop g5 we
play rook take c8 and rook takes c8 rook
takes c8 and the Queen has a dilemma
like she has to take the rook back but
then the Queen will take the bishop and
in this position white is just much
better have another two minor pieces for
a rook blacks King side attack is
falling apart and look why it's just
just better here so obviously you know
Knight Orff was a you know Grand Master
so obviously he saw that threat and the
move he played to defend it was just so
simple he was played Bishop d7 and said
okay what are you gonna do now and
taming I was like I don't know Queen e1
I don't know so now it's time to try to
get the initiative again what move
should black play this is one that like
all the little kids get right instantly
and then the strong players never get
because the little kids just like do the
first thing that looks good and the
strong players spend way too much time
thinking about it and think it's going
to be too complicated if you were still
seven years old what move would you play
in this position Eric that's what you'd
play if you were five years old because
it's just a check a little more mature
than that that's that's a you krabi
where would you go where would you go
Bishop h4 okay you guys have like the
right idea like make a threat but Bishop
g5 is absolutely right Bishop g5 not
Bishop h4 stupid computer Bishop to g5
because one obviously with the attack on
c1 but look at this bishop this once
terrible ugly bishop on f8 that didn't
do anything it's now going to be on III
where it is simply boss so white plays
Knight d2 now kids do you think we
should take the knight
no you shouldn't never trade and in this
case really no I'll take it like no this
should be three check everyone saw that
coming so I didn't ask King over okay
now in this position again what do you
think black should do
with one ideas
matter for um in my opinion and I'm no
Grand Master but the one thing I don't
like about moving a Knight to f4 is that
it allows your opponent to exchange
pieces and we know that that's just one
method of defense that when you're
defending if you can trade off some of
the attackers you be in a little less
trouble which would be good so night of
four makes sense to me but I don't know
I think I'd almost want to bring another
piece into the attack I mean look at
this we have one two three four pieces
that could possibly participate why not
add another now we have five that's like
awesome and not to mention there's some
tactical issues with the knight on D -
if this rook decides to go hunting so
Bishop to f1 this is really a depressing
move to play for white and you're
setting up the pieces before the game is
over it's pretty it's not fun so what
are we supposed to do here for black
what do we think
yep simple enough right
exactly every single piece in the attack
look at the last ten moves white has not
done anything other than just respond to
what blacks doing black is forcing his
will on his opponent and White's
position is about to collapse
so rook d1 once again I don't know what
to do I have to move B five black
prevents the one thing that white could
try to do which was Knight c4 which
really wasn't a huge huge threat anyway
but why bother why let him have anything
so white plays a four what do you think
we play here and hey actually I grand
master Yahshua Sarah Wan is outside and
I would gladly invite him in to fill in
for me if he had actually open the door
and join us well if he decides to he
decides to if not much so anyway so what
we player is black a6 exactly because
it's like you're gonna take me I'm gonna
take you back same problem like you know
it's so Rick c7 and this rook this lone
white rook is gonna save the day for
white nothing on the kingside mattered
this one lone rook is going to take care
of everything
you ready no it's not this goes back and
look at all the pieces around the black
the white King this is just absolutely
devastating
Bishop h3 who can tell me why we can't
take it well you can but why can't you
do that
let's it appropriately vague answer
specifics man okay specifics pawn takes
Bishop than what Queen Queen g1 okay
then Bishop g1 h g1 okay almost after
that King how does that mate thank you
thank you see you saved me I appreciate
that so just to show everybody here
so what was it here Queen to g1 Bishop
rook King h2 and then Knight f3 which is
obviously checkmate so long story short
we are not going to be able to take that
bishop so what do we do Queen you two
well night off comes crashing through
anyway and the rest of this game is just
just basically white just getting
demolished okay Bishop takes back Bishop
takes G - Queen G - and now okay it
looks like white is escaping it looks
like white is able to strain it off some
pieces and is I'm gonna get out of this
alive so what you black - yeah
h4 whoa what are you thinking on anybody
else h4 let's see Queen h4 because this
this White Queen is getting a little low
on squares I mean let's look at every
one of them there's anything on the Jeep
I'm gonna work
hey I'm wearing something anything on
the g5 gonna work no age file no and
anywhere else there's a fork so if Queen
e2 the knight can go to g3 and the same
thing if um what does it clean f1 Knight
g3 so where it is the Queen go she goes
to g7 to get something King takes rook
check King back okay 91 like white is
groveling at this point like black has
got the material advantage the attack
he's got everything so the rest of its
just history Knight of seven that's not
f7 that's f4 route g3 Bishop f2 44 and
what should white play here it was like
a last puzzle since this game is about
over
you sure I don't have the notation
window open here okay good training a
Quidditch three night went back to d2
trying to like hold the f1 obviously
because there was that threat and
holding f3 h v g5 and then after playing
brooke g5 black and white just resigned
said okay I've had enough there's too
many threats well golly gee it's mate 7
thank you Houdini for you ruin chess for
all of us we wanted to find a
combination and you just ruined it
anyway my name is Jo Garnier that's the
game I showed today